We were putting together today's radio show, and we came across this idea that totally changed how we saw the stories that you're going to hear today. This idea was in a talk that George RR Martin gave. He's the guy who wrote the series of fantasy books that Game of Thrones was based on, back in the 1930s and '40s.
我们在筹备今天的广播节目时，偶然发现了一个想法，它完全改变了我们对你们今天即将听到的故事的看法。这个想法来自乔治·R·R·马丁的一次演讲。他就是《权力的游戏》原著系列奇幻小说的作者。
And he was talking about his job on stage in front of some fans, and specifically he was talking about how JRR Tolkien changed everything for people in his kind of work, for people who write fantasy stories. And when I say "changed everything," I don't mean putting a double R in the middle of your name if you're a fantasy writer. Tolkien, of course, wrote Lord of the Rings and The Hobbit .
他在台上向粉丝讲述自己的工作，特别提到了J·R·R·托尔金是如何改变了他这一行——也就是奇幻小说创作者——的一切。当我提到“改变了一切”时，我并不是说如果是个奇幻作家，就得在名字中间加两个R。当然，托尔金创作了《指环王》和《霍比特人》。
And one of the things he did that was extraordinary was create Middle Earth in such detail. If you look at some of the pre-Tolkien fantasy, it's written more in a story of fairy tales. You know, "Once upon a time, there was a king, and the king had a beautiful daughter." But you won't know, like, who was the king's father, or who was his grandfather, how the dynasty came to power, or what the neighboring countries are."
他做了一件非凡的事情，那就是创造了细节极其丰富的中土世界。如果你看看托尔金之前的奇幻作品，它们更像是在写童话故事。你知道的，比如“很久以前，有一个国王，国王有一个漂亮的女儿。”但你根本不知道国王的父亲是谁，祖父是谁，这个王朝是怎么掌权的，或者邻国是哪些。
But Tolkien gave all that, and more. He created whole histories and languages and genealogies. He created stuff that never even appeared in the books.
但托尔金提供了所有这些，甚至更多。他创造了完整的历史、语言和族谱。他甚至创造了一些从未在书中出现过的东西。
And it seemed as real as England or France or Germany when you read these things.
当你读到这些内容时，它看起来和英国、法国或德国一样真实。
Make-believe just has more heft-- it gets to you more, it feels like more-- the more detail there is to make the world in the story feel real. Which when you think about it, of course, is obvious, whether you're telling a story, or you're designing Grand Theft Auto, or you're a spy needing to invent a cover, or you're a cheater or a con man of some kind, making up a scam.
虚构的东西就是更有分量——它越能触动你，越让你感觉真实，是因为故事中的世界细节越丰富。当你仔细想想，这当然是很明显的，无论你是在讲故事，设计《侠盗猎车手》，还是需要伪造身份的间谍，又或者是某种行骗的骗子。
But this idea was interesting to us, because today on our show, we have two stories of make-believe worlds. Act One is about an amazingly successful one. Act Two is about a fantastically unsuccessful one.
但这个想法对我们来说很有趣，因为今天在我们的节目中，有两个关于虚构世界的故事。第一幕是关于一个极其成功的案例，第二幕是关于一个极其失败的案例。
And when we heard that quote from George RR Martin, we realized, right. These worlds live or die, their success or their failure depends, on these details, on how believable they are, how precisely chosen. That's at the heart of both these stories.
当我们听到乔治·R·R·马丁那段话时，我们意识到，没错，这些世界的存亡，它们的成功或失败，都取决于这些细节，取决于它们的可信度以及细节的选择有多精准。这正是这两个故事的核心。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. How make-believe works. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。了解虚构是如何运作的。请继续收听。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Act One: Overboard. So there are 12 kids in the Steinfels family, and they grew up in the 1980s in a very unusual situation. They all worked on a ship. Their dad, Jim, had been in the Navy, and he oversaw them. They swabbed the decks. They served food in the chow line. They wore uniforms-- white sailor hats, black neckerchiefs. Miki Meek tells more.
第一幕：船上。斯坦费尔斯一家有12个孩子，他们在20世纪80年代成长于一种非常不同寻常的环境中。他们都在一艘船上工作。他们的父亲吉姆曾在海军服役，他监管着他们。他们擦洗甲板，在配餐线上分发食物。他们穿着制服——白色的水兵帽，黑色的领巾。米基·米克讲述了更多细节。
When Joe was in elementary school, his favorite part of working on the ship was night watch. That's when all the rest of the crew was asleep.
当乔还在读小学时，他最喜欢的工作是守夜。那是其他船员都在睡觉的时候。
You know, which I loved, you know? I loved it. From midnight to 4:00 in the morning, that was one of my favorite watches, where it's quiet. You're listening to talk radio coming out with their little weather alerts and stuff. And you're sitting there, and every half-hour, you have to get up and walk around and make sure the ship's secure and all that.
你知道，我真的很喜欢，我太爱守夜了。从午夜到凌晨4点，那是我最喜欢的轮班之一，因为很安静。你会听着无线电里传来的天气预报之类的东西。你坐在那里，每半小时就要起来巡视一圈，确保船只安全之类的。
Colder as the evening and morning hours approach.
随着傍晚和清晨的临近，天气越来越冷。
Joe was only six years old, little Navy hat on his head, peering over the side, watching for any incoming threat.
乔当时只有六岁，头上戴着小小的海军帽，从船边探出头，观察是否有任何潜在的威胁。
I remember clearly, you know, there was raccoons one night that were over making noise near the garbage can area.
我记得很清楚，有一天晚上垃圾桶附近有浣熊在制造噪音。
Yes. Raccoons. I should clarify. The ship that he worked on, it was not at sea. It was not moving. It was stationed in the driveway of their house in suburban Chicago. But Joe took his job seriously and kept a logbook that he updated almost every half-hour.
没错。浣熊。我得澄清一下。他工作的这艘船并不在海上。它没有移动。它就停在芝加哥郊区他们家的车道上。但乔非常认真地对待他的工作，并保存了一份日志，几乎每半小时更新一次。
And so I think I annotated something along those lines in the logbook. You know, "2:30 in the morning, raccoons," such and such. So, "Made rounds. All is not secure. Raccoons."
所以我记得在日志里标注了类似的内容。你知道，“凌晨2点30分，浣熊”，诸如此类。“巡视完毕。一切不安全。有浣熊。”
You know, it gave so much officialness to what we were doing. This wasn't just a game. This was-- this was life.
你知道，这让我们做的事情显得非常正式。这不仅仅是一个游戏。这是——这是生活。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
The idea to build a ship in the driveway came from his sister, Elizabeth. They shared a room, and one day when their parents told them to clean it up, Elizabeth made a deal with Joe. If he'd take care of it, she'd build them a ship. She was five; he was four. The big sister. Joe said yes. So Elizabeth dragged a couple boxes into their backyard and started to pull together materials.
在车道上造船的想法来自他的姐姐伊丽莎白。他们共用一个房间，有一天父母让他们打扫房间时，伊丽莎白和乔达成了协议。如果乔负责打扫，她就为他们造一艘船。她五岁，他四岁。姐姐嘛。乔答应了。于是伊丽莎白拖了几个盒子到后院，开始收集材料。
I think I asked my father if I could have some two-by-fours to make the deck with. And then, of course, he got involved, deciding that he was going to take it up a level. You know, signal flags being done up, and portholes in doors, and hand-painted numbers. And I had a gorgeous wood desk, and I had like my own phone, and landlines were run from the house to the ship.
我想我问我父亲能不能给我一些2x4的木料来做甲板。当然，他参与了进来，决定把船升级一下。你知道，挂上信号旗，在门上开舷窗，还有手绘的编号。我有一个漂亮的木书桌，我还有自己的电话，家里还拉了固定电话到船上。
What? Like a real phone?
什么？像真电话一样？
Yeah. Yeah.
对，没错。
What?
什么？
I'm telling you, I had a really nice office there.
我告诉你，我那里的办公室真的很棒。
And then did the ship have a name?
那这艘船有名字吗？
It was the USS Elizabeth City .
它叫“伊丽莎白号”。
As the months went on, the ship grew more and more elaborate. Their dad started using masonite and plywood. He put in a wheelhouse and an engine room. Eventually the ship was about 24 feet long and painted battleship gray.
随着时间的推移，这艘船变得越来越精致。他们的父亲开始使用纤维板和胶合板。他安装了驾驶室和机舱。最终，这艘船大约24英尺长，漆成了战舰灰色。
A lot of the magic was in the accessories. He outfitted the ship with guns that shot ping-pong balls and missiles made from spray-painted deodorant sticks. He picked up life jackets at a Navy surplus store.
很多魔力来自于配件。他给船配备了可以发射乒乓球的枪，还有用喷漆除臭剂棒做的导弹。他从海军盈余商店买了救生衣。
He installed an intercom. It was a long, hollow tube that let you talk from the wheelhouse to the engine room in the back.
他安装了一个内部通讯系统。那是一个长长的中空管子，让你可以在驾驶室和后面的机舱之间说话。
He attached the motor from a blender to a wall. Its purpose? Engine noise. The kids could hit different buttons speeds on it to make it sound like they were moving faster.
他把一个搅拌机的马达装在墙上。它的用途是什么？模拟引擎噪音。孩子们可以按下不同的速度按钮，让声音听起来像是在加速行驶。
What made their dad so good at make-believe is how real he made it. One of the girls, Marion, liked eating breakfast on the ship's deck. Her dad would bring out an old coffee percolator.
让他们的父亲在虚构方面如此成功的原因在于他做得有多真实。其中一个女孩，玛丽恩，喜欢在船甲板上吃早餐。她父亲会拿出一个旧的咖啡过滤器。
And put in the smokestack. And then you would just see the steam kind of rising up out of that. And then we had these little Kool-Aid mugs that had been remade into our coffee cups. And he really would let us have coffee. Like we would just sit around, like in our work gear, getting ready for the day and admiring our ship, with the real-looking steam coming up.
然后把它放进烟囱里。你会看到蒸汽从里面升起来。然后我们有这些小Kool-Aid马克杯，被改造成我们的咖啡杯。他真的会让我们喝咖啡。我们就坐在那里，穿着我们的工作服，准备开始新的一天，欣赏着我们的船，看着那看起来像真的一样的蒸汽升起。
The kids would play on the USS Elizabeth City all summer long, sometimes on 24-hour shifts. Think of what genius parenting that is if you have a dozen kids. When summer comes, you want to keep them busy, engage them. In any given summer, pretty much any kid who wasn't a teenager yet would be on the ship. Again, here's Marion.
孩子们整个夏天都在“伊丽莎白号”上玩耍，有时甚至要值24小时的班。如果你有十二个孩子，想想这是多么天才的育儿方式。夏天来了，你想让他们忙起来，参与其中。在任何一个夏天，基本上任何还没到十几岁的孩子都会在船上。再强调一次，这是玛丽恩说的。
We didn't have many toys. I mean, they were-- at the end of it all, there were 12 of us. But like, then in our backyard, we had the most elaborate and amazing toy any child could ever have, that wasn't just something-- you know, it wasn't like a video game you played for a little bit. It was like years and years and years of playing on, kind of learning on, sleeping outside. It was just such a crazy, like amazing, ya know, experience.
我们没有很多玩具。我的意思是，到最后，我们有12个孩子。但在我们的后院，我们拥有任何孩子梦寐以求的最精致、最神奇的玩具，这不仅仅是——你知道，它不像那种玩一会儿的电子游戏。这是我们玩了多年、在上面学习、在外面睡觉的地方。这真是一种疯狂、神奇的经历。
There was a whole world their dad created around the USS Elizabeth City -- a history and a mission statement, and a strict set of rules and responsibilities. His wife Joan typed up a pamphlet just like the ones the Navy handed out when their ships were at port. In this case, the port was their neighborhood, Park Ridge. Joan read it for me.
他们的父亲在“伊丽莎白号”周围创造了一个完整的世界——一段历史、一份使命宣言，以及一套严格的规则和责任。他的妻子琼打印了一份小册子，就像海军在船只靠港时分发的那种。在这种情况下，港口就是他们所在的帕克里奇社区。琼为我读了那本手册。
"The USS Elizabeth City is one of the most modern classes of driveway gunboats. Many of our officers and enlisted personnel make their homes in this community. Our ship's mission is to defend Park Ridge's strategic Continental Divide against surprise naval attack."
“‘伊丽莎白号’是车道炮艇中最新型的级别之一。我们的许多军官和士兵都在这个社区安家。我们船的使命是保卫帕克里奇的战略大陆分水岭，防止突发的海军袭击。”
Is that what you guys told the kids? This is your mission?
这就是你们告诉孩子们的内容吗？这就是你们的使命？
Right. Right, definitely, yes. And of course, Park Ridge is totally surrounded by land.
没错。是的，绝对是。当然，帕克里奇完全被陆地包围了。
The last paragraph was a message for the crew, his 12 kids.
最后一段是给船员们，也就是他那12个孩子的信息。
" Elizabeth City is a small ship and we can get along best by looking out for each other. Glad to have you with us. We think you're going to like it here. Welcome aboard."
“‘伊丽莎白号’是一艘小船，我们互相照顾才能相处得最好。很高兴你们加入我们。我们认为你们会喜欢这里的。欢迎登船。”
Their dad, Jim, had been in the Navy for about a decade. In his 30s, he married Joan. They eventually ran an architecture firm together out of their basement. They didn't make much money. They spent most of their time designing youth centers in low-income neighborhoods throughout Chicago.
他们的父亲吉姆在海军服役了大约十年。他30多岁时娶了琼。他们最终在自家地下室经营一家建筑事务所。他们没赚多少钱。他们大部分时间都在为芝加哥低收入社区设计青少年中心。
But Jim didn't just design these. For more than 40 years, he also helped maintain them, would deal with emergency calls in the middle of the night if a pipe broke. And when he'd go to make repairs, he'd bring the kids to help. He was idealistic, and also incredibly practical.
但吉姆不仅仅是设计这些。四十多年来，他一直负责维护它们，如果在半夜管道破裂，他还会处理紧急电话。当他去修理时，他会带上孩子们帮忙。他很有理想，也极其务实。
He died in 2011 and never talked to his wife and kids about what he'd hoped they'd get out of the ship. But they do know that he enjoyed playing in that world just as much as they did. Every kid I spoke to described his incredible imagination-- not just with the ship.
他于2011年去世，从未与妻子和孩子们谈论过他希望他们从这艘船中得到什么。但他们确实知道，他像他们一样享受在那个虚构世界里玩耍的过程。我采访的每个孩子都描述了他惊人的想象力——不仅仅是在船上。
There were the stories he'd make up, the Fisher Price city he built in their basement, a trading post he ran from a window in his office. The kids could get trinkets in exchange for trash they cleaned out of their yard. He printed fake money once, and they played the stock market for three months.
他编造的故事，他在地下室建造的费雪牌城市，他在办公室窗户经营的贸易站。孩子们可以用他们从院子里清理出来的垃圾换取小玩意儿。他曾印刷过假币，他们还玩了三个月的股市。
He made stuff fun. They all talked about that. But he also had an intense work ethic and thrived on discipline and teamwork. He wanted his kids to be productive and constantly told them--
他让一切变得有趣。他们都提到了这一点。但他也有极强的工作道德，热衷于纪律和团队合作。他希望孩子们多产，并不断告诉他们——
If you have time to lean, you have time to clean. He wanted you to be working.
如果你有时间靠着休息，你就有时间去打扫。他希望你一直工作。
Again, this is Marion. She told me her dad assigned each of them a specific job. For example, she was the hospital corpsman, which meant she was responsible for any injuries on the ship.
还是玛丽恩。她说她父亲给他们每个人分配了特定的工作。例如，她是医院医护兵，这意味着她负责船上的任何受伤情况。
I had like a real first aid kit. I had like a little station there. I mean, it was full of, like, my fake shots and stuff. But I had like real alcohol, real Band-Aids, real ACE bandage, you know, stuff like that.
我有一个真正的急救箱。我在那里有一个小小的岗位。我的意思是，它装满了我的假针头之类的东西。但我有真正的酒精、真正的创可贴、真正的弹性绷带，你知道，诸如此类的东西。
What's the worst injury you had to treat?
你处理过的最严重的伤是什么？
Like people always got splinters because it was wood. And all my siblings had a service record, or--
人们总是因为木头而长刺。而且我所有的兄弟姐妹都有服役记录，或者——
Is it a medical record, or what?
是医疗记录吗，还是什么？
Real medical records. And that was another job of mine, is that whenever the kids went to real medical appointments with the doctor, my mom would come back with, you know, that you get a sheet from the doctor or whatever if you had a shot and stuff. And my mom would give them, to me, and my job was to hole-punch them and to put them in their proper service jacket. And once in a while, my dad would say, will you check and see if anyone's behind on their appointments or whatever?
真正的医疗记录。这也是我的工作之一，每当孩子们去医生那里看病时，我妈妈回来后，你知道，如果你打了针之类的，你会从医生那里得到一张单子。我妈妈会把它们交给我，我的工作是用打孔机打孔，然后把它们放进他们各自的服役档案里。偶尔，我爸爸会说，你能检查一下看看有没有人错过了预约或者别的什么吗？
And you know, I mean, I took that very seriously. Like I was very proud that I had that job. I had this responsibility to make sure all the kids were going to the doctor on time.
而且你知道，我非常认真地对待这件事。我为自己有这份工作感到非常自豪。我有责任确保所有的孩子都按时去看医生。
Other kids on the ship had positions like gunner's mate, radio men, master-at-arms, and culinary specialist. And each of these involve some paperwork, real US Navy paperwork, forms that their dad saved from his time in the service or picked up from local recruitment offices. Elizabeth, who was the chief storekeeper, says she spent many hours putting her signature on supply requisitions.
船上的其他孩子担任诸如炮手长、无线电员、军士长和烹饪专家等职位。每个人都涉及到一些文书工作，真正的美国海军文书工作，这些表格是他们父亲从服役期间保留的，或者是从当地征兵办公室拿来的。伊丽莎白是首席仓库管理员，她说她花了很多时间在补给申请单上签字。
If someone was supposed to be doing some sort of job and they needed specific tools, or they were supposed to cook something and needed oatmeal or coriander--
如果有人应该做某种工作，他们需要特定的工具，或者他们应该做点什么吃的，需要燕麦或香菜——
Or coriander?
或者香菜？
In the kitchen-- yeah. Yeah.
在厨房里——是的。是的。
[BOTH LAUGH]
[两人笑]
They would have to come to me, maybe with a work order. It was a lot of-- lot of initials. It was just more about routine and paperwork.
他们得来找我，可能带着工作申请单。有很多很多的缩写。这更多是关于例行公事和文书工作。
So what made this fun? I think that's the thing I'm trying to figure out. Because it sounds like it's a lot of work.
那是什么让这变得有趣呢？我想这就是我试图弄明白的事情。因为听起来这需要做很多工作。
Um, I don't know. I don't know that it always was fun. You know, when we were on there, my memory is it was somewhere between work and play. I think I liked that I had a defined character and everything. Grumpy old storekeeper, and you know.
嗯，我不知道。我不确定它是否总是那么有趣。你知道，当我们在船上时，我的记忆是它介于工作和玩耍之间。我想我喜欢我有明确的角色设定。脾气暴躁的老仓库管理员，你知道。
So did your dad coach you?
那你父亲会指导你吗？
Of course. Of course. It's just like a little snarly, and not enough coffee. No, I'm not going to get you that right now. You're going to have to wait, or fill out the right paperwork. Or you know, I don't know.
当然。当然。就像有点咆哮，而且咖啡不够。不，我现在不会给你那个。你得等一等，或者填好正确的表格。或者你知道，我不知道。
Just because that's what my father, he just remembered that every chief storekeeper that he had ever known had always had this, like, little stub of a cigar hanging out of the corner of his mouth, as he snarled at you about something. And so he felt that it was very important that I always had this little ashtray on my desk with just a smoldering little cigar on it.
只是因为我父亲记得他认识的每一位首席仓库管理员在对你咆哮某事时，嘴角总是叼着一小截雪茄。所以他觉得我办公桌上总是放着一个装着冒烟雪茄的小烟灰缸非常重要。
She was six.
她当时六岁。
Of course, with so many kids, there were arguments and disagreements on the ship. And so to deal with that, their dad created a chain of command, an entire rank structure. He gave himself one of the lower positions, the boatswain's mate. That way the kids would have to work out problems on their own.
当然，孩子那么多，船上肯定会有争吵和分歧。为了处理这些问题，他们父亲建立了一个指挥链，一个完整的等级结构。他给自己安排了一个较低的职位，水手长。这样孩子们就不得不自己解决问题。
The highest-ranking position, commanding officer, that went to his oldest child, Jane. She was in charge of posting a plan of the day. That included chores, meals, and watch times for her brothers and sisters.
最高等级的指挥官职位给了他最大的孩子简。她负责发布当天的日程安排。包括家务、用餐和兄弟姐妹的值班时间。
If they all did their jobs, their dad would take them for doughnuts at the end of the week. Any kid who slacked off would ruin it for everyone. And if Jane caught them slacking off at their jobs, as commanding officer she had the power to punish. Like she could make you guard garbage cans as a time-out.
如果他们都完成了工作，周末父亲会带他们去买甜甜圈。任何偷懒的孩子都会毁了大家的福利。如果简发现他们偷懒，作为指挥官，她有权惩罚他们。比如她可以罚你去看守垃圾桶作为禁闭。
I was seen as bossy and as always telling them what to do. And, you know, it didn't matter that that was my job, that that was what I had been assigned to do.
我被视为爱管闲事，总是指挥他们。而且，你知道，我被指派做这项工作，这是我的职责，这并不重要。
So like, let me give you an example of that.
那，让我给你举个例子。
If I was in charge and I didn't think your brass belt buckle was shined adequately, that might be a source of tension. But if you're going to wear a uniform, then you better-- you better wear it.
如果我负责，而我认为你的铜皮带扣擦得不够亮，那可能会引起紧张。但如果你要穿制服，那你最好——你最好把它穿好。
So I mean, like in some way, it created a little bit of a separation between you and the rest of them.
所以我的意思是，在某种程度上，这在你和其他人之间造成了一点隔阂。
I mean, of course. It's only-- it's only natural. I mean, but what's which actually kind of funny is that I was never allowed, not one single time, to play, because that was fraternization.
我的意思是，当然。这是很自然的。但实际上很有趣的是，我从来没有被允许，一次都没有，去玩，因为那是“搞派系”。
What?
什么？
I was an officer. They were enlisted. I was not allowed to have that relationship with them, that I could sit around the table with them and play cards.
我是军官。他们是士兵。我不被允许和他们有那种关系，我不能和他们围坐在桌边打牌。
When you came back in the house, were you allowed to play together?
当你回到屋里时，你们被允许一起玩吗？
Yeah. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. No, it was just-- it was just on the ship. You know, that was kind of the cost I paid for the role that I had.
可以。哦，当然可以。不，只是——只是在船上不可以。你知道，这是我为我的角色所付出的代价。
I asked them all, why did they keep playing along with this? So many rules. So much cleaning.
我问他们所有人，为什么你们会一直配合这个游戏？这么多规矩。这么多清理工作。
They said, you're a little kid, so it is fun. Like a treehouse and a fort and dress-up, all rolled into one. And they said when you're a little kid, you want to do with the older kids are doing, whatever it is. And then you had your dad there, always adding these extra details to keep them excited, like sudden deployment orders.
他们说，你是个小孩子，所以这很有趣。就像树屋、堡垒和变装游戏结合在一起。他们说当你还是个孩子时，你总是想做大孩子做的事情，无论那是什么。而且你有父亲在场，总是增加这些额外的细节来让他们感到兴奋，比如突然的部署命令。
The USS Elizabeth City was on wheels and went on trips. Joe remembers being called on a mission to a church parking lot down the street.
“伊丽莎白号”是有轮子的，还会去旅行。乔记得曾接到任务前往街下的一家教堂停车场。
And we would push this 24-foot-long ship out into a relatively busy street, Cumberland Avenue, and we would make corners. And one of us would be in the wheelhouse, actually steering the wheel of the ship. And we'd do drills. We'd do target practice, if you will, with a little submarine.
我们会把这艘24英尺长的船推到一条相对繁忙的街道，坎伯兰大道上，我们要转弯。我们中的一个人会坐在驾驶室里，实际操控船舵。我们会进行演习。我们会用潜艇进行目标练习。
This is back in the '80s. The Cold War was a threat. So we'd have a little Soviet-era submarine that would be out there, moving around. And we'd have "man overboard" drills, and everyone would throw on their life preservers. And I mean, even though I can clearly see asphalt sitting there, somewhere in my mind, you know, it seemed like it was real.
这是80年代。冷战是个威胁。所以我们有一个小型的苏联时代潜艇在那儿，四处移动。我们还会进行“人员落水”演习，每个人都会穿上救生衣。我的意思是，尽管我可以清楚地看到脚下的柏油路，但在我的脑海里，你知道，它看起来好像是真的。
They lived so fully in the world of the ship, their lives were so devoted to it, that the kids never really stopped to think about how someone from the outside world might view it. Marion says she was eight before she first invited a friend aboard the USS Elizabeth City .
他们如此沉浸在船的世界里，他们的生活如此投入，以至于孩子们从来没有想过外人会怎么看。玛丽恩说她八岁时第一次邀请朋友上“伊丽莎白号”。
I was out there with my other brothers and sisters, and she just kept kind of rolling her eyes, being like, what are we doing? And she wanted to go inside and play Barbies, and this was kind of like weird. I think that was when I first realized, like, not everyone had ships in their backyards.
我和我的兄弟姐妹在外面，她只是不停地翻白眼，好像在说，我们在干什么？她想进屋去玩芭比娃娃，这感觉有点怪。我想那是第一次我意识到，并不是每个人家里后院都有船。
And so I mean, did you just not acknowledge that you had a ship in your backyard after that?
所以我的意思是，在那之后你就假装你家后院没船了吗？
Yeah, I think for the rest of grammar school, I just-- it was like, they just need to know. Its on a need-to-know basis.
是的，我想在小学剩下的时间里，我只是——就像，他们只需要知道。这是基于“需要知道”的原则。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
All the Steinfels kids, they eventually reached an age-- usually around middle school-- when they started wanting to spend more time off the ship than on it. And their dad, he created a system to deal with that, too. Here's David, the 11th of the Steinfels' 12 kids.
斯坦费尔斯所有的孩子最终都到了一个年龄——通常在初中左右——他们开始想要在船外花更多的时间。他们的父亲也建立了一套系统来处理这个问题。这是大卫，斯坦费尔斯家12个孩子里的第11个。
If you wanted to take liberty, you'd have to fill out a yellow slip and then put where you were going. You had to put the time and date of when you were leaving and when you're coming back. And then you had to put who you're going to see, what you're doing, a number to reach you at, like, your Social Security number. And then you'd have to get it signed off by the supervisor of the day. And then--
如果你想请假，你必须填一张黄色申请条，然后写上你要去哪里。你必须填上离开和回来的时间和日期。然后你必须填上你要去见谁，做什么，联系电话，比如你的社会安全号码。然后你必须让当天的监督员签字。然后——
So you mean an older sibling, or what?
所以你是说让大一点的兄弟姐妹签字，或者什么的？
So the supervisor would be whoever was appointed. Then it would get posted. And I don't think my father really ever had to step in, or-- I think that's one of the beauties of the system, is like, use the other siblings to keep everything in order.
监督员就是被任命的那个人。然后它会被张贴出来。我不觉得我父亲真的需要干预，或者——我认为这是这套系统的美妙之处，就是利用其他兄弟姐妹来保持一切秩序。
As the kids got older, they just stopped showing up on the ship to play. Only one kid I spoke with formally requested a discharge. She was 12.
随着孩子们长大，他们就不再出现在船上玩了。我采访的孩子中只有一个正式要求退役。她当时12岁。
I went to my dad and, you know, acting very seriously, told him that I'd thought about it, and I had decided that it just wasn't for me anymore.
我去找我父亲，你知道，表现得非常严肃，告诉他我已经考虑过了，我决定这不再适合我了。
This is Marion.
这是玛丽恩。
He was just like, OK, that's interesting. And I remember getting in the mail, not too long after that, a big manila envelope, you know, to Hospital Corpsman Third Class Marion Kate. And inside, there was a letter that said, unfortunately, because we had just entered the first Gulf War, that the President had said that no one can leave right now, that everyone's automatically re-enlisted.
他只是说，好吧，那很有意思。我记得在那之后不久，我在信箱里收到一个大的牛皮纸信封，你知道，写给三级医院医护兵玛丽恩·凯特。里面有一封信，说很不幸，因为我们刚刚进入第一次海湾战争，总统说现在没有人可以离开，每个人都被自动重新征召入伍。
This was an actual real order that came down for actual sailors during Operation Desert Storm. Probably not intended for middle school kids in Illinois.
这是沙漠风暴行动期间对真正的水兵发布的真实命令。可能并不是针对伊利诺伊州的中学生。
And so I wasn't going to be able to leave then. And I mean, I was just like, you know, kind of like, OK, he got me, I guess. I mean, there's just no getting out of it.
所以我当时没法离开了。我的意思是，我就像，你知道，有点像是，好吧，他逮住我了，我想。我的意思是，根本没法逃脱。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Jane, the oldest, is 41 now. The youngest, Samuel, is 20. And you can't help but notice how much the Steinfels kids' lives seem to be shaped by their time on the ship.
简，最大的孩子，现在41岁了。最小的塞缪尔，20岁。你不能不注意到斯坦费尔斯的孩子们的生活似乎在多大程度上受到了船上时光的影响。
Elizabeth, the master chief storekeeper, she now runs her own clothing store. John, the culinary specialist, he manages the kitchen at a Chicago restaurant. Samuel's training to be an officer at the Naval Academy right now. Jane went there, too.
伊丽莎白，首席仓库管理员，现在经营着自己的服装店。约翰，烹饪专家，管理着芝加哥一家餐厅的厨房。塞缪尔现在正在海军学院接受军官培训。简也去过那里。
Four of the other boys, they ended up in the Marine Corps. David enlisted right after high school. He's been deployed to Asia and Yemen.
其他四个男孩最终都进了海军陆战队。大卫高中毕业后就参军了。他被派驻到亚洲和也门。
I think the ship was a very big part. Because the one thing that I was good at, and I knew it because we did it as a child, was the military. And when I went there, it was pretty easy for me. I mean, all these other people were struggling, especially Marine boot camp. It's a-- it's a legendary zone of horror and pain and whatnot, but I was pretty used to it. I mean, it wasn't obviously as intense at home as it was there. But a lot of the rules and everything, like organization, attention to detail, it was all pretty much mirrored.
我认为船是一个非常大的部分。因为我擅长的一件事，而且我知道这一点，是因为我们小时候这样做过，那就是军事。当我到了那里，对我来说很容易。我的意思是，所有其他人在挣扎，尤其是海军陆战队新兵训练营。那是一个——这是一个充满恐惧和痛苦的传奇地带，但我已经习惯了。我的意思是，这显然不像家里那么激烈。但很多规则和一切，比如组织能力、对细节的关注，几乎都是一样的。
When you actually got on a real ship, how similar was it to your play ship?
当你真正踏上一艘真正的船时，它和你的游戏船有多相似？
[CHUCKLES] A lot of it was surprisingly the same. I mean, I could still, from my bed, reach out and touch three different people. And you could hear people breathing in their beds.
[笑声] 很多地方出奇地一样。我的意思是，我仍然可以在床上伸手触碰到三个不同的人。而且你可以听到人们在床上呼吸的声音。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Jim Steinfels was 71 when he died from cancer four years ago. He wanted his kids to be competent and industrious and serve something bigger than themselves, lessons they say they learned on the ship. Right after he died, Marion said they couldn't stop thinking about how he would have hated anyone wasting a good day of work.
吉姆·斯坦费尔斯四年前因癌症去世时71岁。他希望他的孩子们能干、勤奋，并为比他们自身更伟大的事业服务，这是他们说在船上学到的教训。在他去世后，玛丽恩说他们忍不住一直在想，他会多么痛恨有人浪费美好的一天去工作。
My mom, one thing that she kind of struggled with was having his funeral during the day. She thought that he would be mortified that people had stopped working to go to his funeral. So she thought about having it in the evening.
我妈，有一件事她挺挣扎的，就是要在白天举行他的葬礼。她认为他会因为人们停止工作去参加他的葬礼而感到羞愧。所以她想在晚上举行。
And my dad actually built his own coffin. I mean, he always made-- you know, I mean, he made the ship. He was really good at making things.
我爸爸其实自己造了他的棺材。我的意思是，他总是做——你知道，我的意思是，他造了那艘船。他真的很擅长制作东西。
I just miss being on the ship. I mean, and I think that we all wouldn't have the relationships we have. I mean, I really think it was kind of the basis for our closeness and our kind of like camaraderie.
我只是很怀念在船上的日子。我的意思是，我认为我们都不会有现在的关系。我的意思是，我真的认为那是我们亲密关系和友谊的基础。
The ship their dad build is still around. It's in the garage at their mom's house. And every once in a while, when the kids are home visiting, they'll pull it back into their yard. Sometimes they'll climb back on it, though it's tough to get through the portholes and doors now. And then they'll stand on the deck and watch their own children play on it.
他们父亲造的那艘船还在。它在他们妈妈家的车库里。偶尔，当孩子们回家探亲时，他们会把它拉回院子里。有时他们会爬回去，虽然现在要穿过舷窗和门有点困难了。然后他们会站在甲板上，看着自己的孩子在上面玩耍。
At the bridge, Mom. [INAUDIBLE].
驾驶台，妈妈。[听不清]。
[FOGHORN BLARES]
[雾角声响]
Battle station.
战斗岗位。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Miki Meek is one of producers of our show. If you're curious, pictures of the USS Elizabeth City are at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。如果你好奇的话，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上看到“伊丽莎白号”的照片。
[MUSIC - BOB DYLAN, "WHEN THE SHIP COMES IN"]
[音乐 - 鲍勃·迪伦，《当船进来时》]
Coming up, pretending to be a normal person can be the most difficult make-believe of all. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，假装成一个正常人可能是最困难的虚构。一分钟后，芝加哥公共广播节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。
Today's show, "Land of Make-Believe," we have stories of people constructing worlds that are not real, some more convincingly and charmingly than others. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Lyin' Kings.
今天的节目，“虚构的土地”，我们有关于人们构建非真实世界的故事，有些人比其他人更令人信服、更有魅力。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，说谎的国王。
So this next story is about a whole bunch of people who are building an elaborate world of make-believe for their jobs, and they fail. They totally fail. This is not a spoiler. They don't come close to getting this right. I'm telling you up front. Jonathan Menjivar explains what happened.
所以接下来的这个故事是关于一大群人，他们为了工作建立了一个复杂的虚构世界，但他们失败了。他们彻底失败了。这不是剧透。他们根本没能把这件事做好。我提前告诉你。乔纳森·门吉瓦尔解释了发生了什么。
A warning, if you're listening to the podcast or online version of our program-- there's cursing in the story that we beeped out on the radio. But on the internet we have unbeeped it. If you're listening with kids or you just prefer a beeped show, as always, you can find that at our website. OK, here's Jonathan.
一个警告，如果你正在听播客或在线版本的节目——故事中有一些我们在广播中消音的咒骂。但在互联网上我们没有消音。如果你和孩子一起听，或者你更喜欢消音版节目，像往常一样，你可以在我们的网站上找到它。好的，这是乔纳森。
This story starts with a lie between friends. One of those friends was a young woman named Lyric R. Cabral. She lived in Harlem and had this neighbor, a guy in his 50s named Saeed Torres.
这个故事始于朋友之间的谎言。其中一个朋友是一位名叫莉莉克·R·卡布拉尔的年轻女性。她住在哈莱姆区，有一个邻居，一个50多岁的男人，名叫赛义德·托雷斯。
Lyric's apartment was on the third floor of a brownstone. Saeed lived on the first. And they hung out together all the time. They're both black and Muslim.
莉莉克的公寓在褐砂石建筑的三楼。赛义德住在二楼。他们经常在一起玩。他们都是黑人，也是穆斯林。
And Lyric found Saeed intriguing, in part because he was an actual Black Panther. Lyric had grown up interested in the Black Panther Party but had never actually met a member before. She was a student at the time, learning to do documentary work.
莉莉克觉得赛义德很有趣，部分原因是他确实曾是黑豹党成员。莉莉克从小就对黑豹党感兴趣，但从未真正见过成员。她当时是一名学生，正在学习纪录片制作。
Saeed had told Lyric that he was going to be moving to the Bronx soon. And then one day she came home from school.
赛义德告诉莉莉克他很快要搬到布朗克斯区。然后有一天她从学校回来。
I usually stopped in his apartment to say hello, just because it was before I went upstairs, I would pass his apartment. And when I looked in the apartment, all of his things were gone. There was no furniture. There was no indication that anyone had ever lived there.
我通常会去他公寓打个招呼，因为在我上楼之前我会经过他的公寓。当我往公寓里看时，他所有的东西都不见了。没有家具。没有任何迹象表明有人曾经住过那里。
And I assumed that he had probably just moved to the Bronx. But I thought it weird, because I was like, you know, it was too hasty. He would have told me.
我以为他可能只是搬到了布朗克斯区。但我觉得很奇怪，因为我想，你知道，这太仓促了。他应该会告诉我的。
And while I'm staring at the empty apartment, I get a call from him. He sounds incredibly frantic. I had never heard that tone in his voice. He sounded like almost someone was on the other end of the phone with a gun to his head.
就在我盯着空荡荡的公寓时，接到了他的电话。他听起来极其疯狂。我从未听过他那样的语气。他听起来就像电话那头有人拿着枪指着他的头。
And he said, if anyone comes looking for me, if anyone asks you any information about me, don't give it to them. And you find out who they are for me.
他说，如果有人来找我，如果有人向你询问关于我的任何信息，不要告诉他们。你要帮我找出他们是谁。
And I said, well-- you know, I was pretty petrified based on the way he sounded. He sounded incredibly nervous. And so I said, well, where are you? What's wrong?
我说，嗯——你知道，基于他的语气，我非常害怕。他听起来极其紧张。所以我说，那你现在在哪？出什么事了？
And he's like, well, I can't really tell you, but I'm in South Carolina right now. I have something to tell you. You should come down here and visit.
他说，我没法告诉你，但我现在在南卡罗来纳州。我有些话要告诉你。你应该过来看看。
Which she did. And Saeed told her that all these years she'd known him, all these years she'd seen him getting dressed in nice suits and going to work, that was all a cover. Because Saeed was actually an informant for the FBI.
她确实去了。赛义德告诉她，这些年她认识他，这些年她看着他穿着漂亮的西装去上班，那都是伪装。因为赛义德实际上是FBI的线人。
She says, at the time, she didn't know much about how FBI investigations work.
她说，当时，她对FBI的调查是如何运作的了解不多。
So it was a very naive back-and-forth, but it was very braggadocious on his part. He outlined all that he had done, sort of, for the FBI. And when I asked him, why are you telling me this? He goes, well, because you don't have to fact-check me. You were there.
所以那是一次非常天真的交流，但他非常自夸。他概述了他为FBI所做的一切。当我问他，你为什么要告诉我这些？他说，嗯，因为你不需要去核实我。你当时就在现场。
"There" in that first floor apartment in Harlem. Saeed told Lyric that the FBI had paid his rent while he investigated a man named Tariq Shah. And Lyric knew exactly who that was, because Saeed had introduced her to Tariq. He'd come to Saeed's apartment several times when she was there. Saeed also told Lyric that his whole apartment was wired.
在哈莱姆区一楼的那个公寓里。赛义德告诉莉莉克，FBI支付了他的租金，而他正在调查一个名叫塔里克·沙阿的人。莉莉克很清楚那个人是谁，因为赛义德把她介绍给了塔里克。他曾在她在场时去过赛义德的公寓好几次。赛义德还告诉莉莉克，他的整个公寓都被安装了窃听器。
I was pissed. You know, I mean definitely, this was not like-- I didn't receive this information with a smile. I definitely felt betrayed. Because to me, that meant that I had an FBI file.
我很生气。你知道，我的意思是绝对的，这并不是像——我并没有微笑着接受这些信息。我绝对感到被背叛了。因为对我来说，这意味着我有一份FBI档案。
I mean, and that was a question I had for him. I was like, well, since I was in the apartment with Tariq, I was on camera, correct? And to date, I have not gotten a good answer, both from the FBI-- sort of FOIA'd that material. That FBI has told me they do not have anything in their possession.
我的意思是，这是一个我问他的问题。我说，既然我和塔里克在同一个公寓里，我被摄像机拍到了，对吧？迄今为止，我没有从FBI那里得到一个好的答案——我通过信息自由法案调取了那些材料。FBI告诉我，他们手头没有任何关于我的记录。
And Saeed himself says, oh, no, I would never record you. I would never press Play when you were there. I would never press Record. But I'm not quite too confident in that.
赛义德本人说，哦，不，我永远不会记录你。你在这里的时候我绝不会按播放键。我绝不会按录音键。但我并不太相信这一点。
Lyric says that there in South Carolina, Saeed handed her a folder full of newspaper articles about cases he'd worked on. He'd actually highlighted the parts in the articles that talked about his role, places where he's identified just as "government informant."
莉莉克说，在南卡罗来纳州，赛义德递给她一个装满关于他曾参与案件的报纸文章的文件夹。他实际上在文章中高亮显示了讨论他角色的部分，那些他被标识为“政府线人”的地方。
And Lyric believed him, believed that he'd been an informant, that he'd fled to South Carolina because he was afraid for his safety after the FBI arrested Tariq Shah.
莉莉克相信了他，相信他是线人，因为他在FBI逮捕塔里克·沙阿后害怕自己的安全而逃到了南卡罗来纳州。
Lyric didn't know exactly why Saeed was telling her all of this, but he mentioned he'd seen other people turning the work they'd done with the FBI into bestselling books. Why couldn't he do something similar? And that's where things stood, for nearly a decade.
莉莉克并不完全知道赛义德为什么告诉她这些，但他提到他曾看到其他人将他们与FBI合作所做的工作变成了畅销书。为什么他不能做类似的事情呢？事情就这样持续了近十年。
Lyric kept in touch with Saeed and started pursuing a career as a documentary filmmaker. She met another filmmaker named David Felix Sutcliffe. And David told her that he'd been fantasizing about making a film that would follow an FBI informant.
莉莉克与赛义德保持联系，并开始从事纪录片导演的工作。她遇到了另一位名叫大卫·菲利克斯·萨特克里夫的导演。大卫告诉她，他一直幻想拍一部关于跟踪FBI线人的电影。
And she said, funny you should say, because I-- I know one.
她说，你这么说真巧，因为我——我认识一个。
That's David, by the way. He and Lyric reached out to Saeed, and he told them that he was just starting to work on a new case in Pittsburgh.
顺便说一句，这就是大卫。他和莉莉克联系了赛义德，赛义德告诉他们他刚开始在匹兹堡负责一个新案子。
And, you know, for reasons that weren't totally clear to us at the time, he said, yeah, sure, let's do this. Let's-- you guys can film me.
而且，你知道，出于当时我们不太清楚的原因，他说，好的，没问题。你们可以拍我。
So what's going on? You didn't come down here with no cameras and all that. I asked you that earlier.
那到底是怎么回事？你们当初过来时没带摄像机什么的。我早先问过你。
No, you did not--
不，你没有——
Sure, they could film. But Saeed often got annoyed when they showed up. It was unpredictable when he'd be OK with it.
当然，他们可以拍摄。但当他们出现时，赛义德经常感到恼火。他什么时候能接受拍摄是不可预测的。
I said don't come down here with no goddamn cameras and stuff. Hello? I told you I didn't want my face in this shit. You'd be surprised who knows me. Everybody in Brooklyn know me.
我说过别带什么该死的摄像机过来。喂？我告诉过你我不想让我的脸出现在这些屁事里。你会惊讶有谁认识我。布鲁克林所有人都认识我。
But they don't know where you are.
但他们不知道你在哪。
And they know me in Harlem, too. They know my face.
哈莱姆区的人也认识我。他们认识我的脸。
But they don't know where you are.
但他们不知道你在哪。
I might not even make no fucking independent film, motherfuckers come after me.
我可能连个该死的独立电影都拍不成，那些混蛋会来找我的。
That clip is from the documentary Lyric and David ended up making. It's called (T)ERROR . It follows Saeed as he's working this investigation in Pittsburgh.
这段剪辑来自莉莉克和大卫最终拍摄的纪录片。它叫《恐怖》(T)ERROR。它跟踪记录了赛义德在匹兹堡进行的调查。
And in case this isn't clear, I want to point out how incredibly rare this footage is. Because normally when you hear a story about an FBI counterterrorism investigation, it's pieced together after the fact, using court records and whatever interviews reporters can get with people who will talk.
如果这还不清楚，我想指出这种镜头是多么罕见。因为通常当你听到关于FBI反恐调查的故事时，它是事后拼凑出来的，使用法庭记录和记者能从愿意交谈的人那里得到的任何采访。
Here, Lyric and David were following someone who usually doesn't talk in the first place, an FBI informant. They were following him in real time, while he was actively working a case. So they didn't have to rely on Saeed's memory to document what happened. They were there.
在这里，莉莉克和大卫跟踪的是一个通常根本不会说话的人，一个FBI线人。他们是在实时跟踪他，当时他正积极地处理案件。所以他们不需要依赖赛义德的记忆来记录发生了什么。他们在现场。
They hung out with him in his FBI safe house. He showed them pictures he'd pinned on the wall of targets he said the FBI was interested in. As best as anyone can tell, the FBI never agreed to this. And apparently they never noticed that Lyric and David were filming all this time. I mean, why would they have let the investigation continue, if they knew?
他们和他一起待在他的FBI安全屋里。他给他们展示了贴在墙上的照片，那些他说FBI感兴趣的目标。据所知，FBI从未同意这一点。显然他们从未注意到莉莉克和大卫一直在拍摄。我的意思是，如果他们知道，他们为什么要让调查继续下去呢？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Saeed's primary target, the POI-- Person of Interest-- in Pittsburgh was a man Khalifa Ali al-Akili. Khalifa's a white guy, a convert to Islam. Here's a video he posted to YouTube. He's got a beard, a white turban.
赛义德在匹兹堡的主要目标，POI——相关人员——是一个名叫哈利法·阿里·阿基利的人。哈利法是一个白人，皈依了伊斯兰教。这是他在YouTube上发布的一个视频。他留着胡子，戴着白色的头巾。
My name is Khalifa al-Akili, and I am from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, the United States of America. [SPEAKING ARABIC]. The belly of the beast. La ilaha illallah Muhammadur Rasulallah.
我的名字是哈利法·阿基利，我来自美利坚合众国宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡。[说阿拉伯语]。野兽的腹部。万物非主，唯有安拉；穆罕默德是安拉的使者。
He would engage in sort of-- not inflammatory, but I would say controversial First Amendment-protected speech.
他会从事某种——不是煽动性的，但我会说是受第一修正案保护的争议性言论。
Lyric says Khalifa did a lot of this on Facebook.
莉莉克说哈利法在Facebook上做了很多这类事情。
He would post things such as, you know, 2,000 people died on 9/11. However, X number of Muslims have been killed in the wars on Iraq and Afghanistan. You know, who is the real enemy here? Things like this.
他会发表一些言论，比如，你知道，9/11事件中有2000人死亡。然而，伊拉克和阿富汗战争中杀死了X数量的穆斯林。你知道，谁才是真正的敌人？诸如此类的话。
He would also post videos like, here's Osama bin Laden reading the Quran. There's many Quran recitations you could post on your public Facebook profile after 9/11. You know, he also had another post that said the Taliban are the perfect wearers of the turban.
他还会在视频上发布这样的东西，这是奥萨马·本·拉登在读古兰经。9/11之后，你可以在你的公共Facebook主页上发布许多古兰经朗诵。你知道，他还发了另一条帖子，说塔利班是完美的头巾佩戴者。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Saeed's job was to get close to Khalifa, see if he was doing more than just talking. And the FBI gave him a cover. They told him to say he was working for the Red Cross.
赛义德的工作是接近哈利法，看他是否做了不仅仅是说话的事情。FBI给了他一个伪装。他们告诉他说他在为红十字会工作。
They set him up in a safe house, in an apartment one block from Khalifa, and he went by a different name. And just so this doesn't get confusing, from this point on in the story, we're going to refer to Saeed by that name. That name was Sharif.
他们把他安置在一个安全屋里，就在离哈利法一个街区的地方，他换了个名字。为了不产生混淆，从故事的这一点开始，我们将用那个名字称呼赛义德。那个名字是谢里夫。
So Sharif-- again, that's Saeed undercover-- he started going to the same mosque as Khalifa. And then he actually met him. Sharif bumped into Khalifa on the street one day and introduced himself. Here's how he described Khalifa in the film.
所以谢里夫——再强调一遍，那是卧底的赛义德——他开始去哈利法所在的清真寺。然后他真的遇到了他。谢里夫有一天在街上撞见了哈利法并作了自我介绍。他在电影中是这样描述哈利法的。
The way I see him running around here now, it would make any motherfucker suspicious. He's walking around looking like a Taliban.
我看着他现在到处跑的样子，任何混蛋都会起疑心。他看起来就像个塔利班。
Khalifa had grown up Protestant and converted to Islam when he was 14. In 2001, he went to prison for selling drugs. It was a felony. Over the years, Khalifa had other charges, for having a gun without a license, and assault.
哈利法是在新教环境中长大的，14岁时皈依了伊斯兰教。2001年，他因贩毒入狱。那是重罪。多年来，哈利法还有过其他指控，因为无照持枪和袭击。
And Khalifa was public about his conversion. He'd proselytize. Neighbors in his apartment building say that he'd slip Islamic brochures under their doors and take down Christmas cards they'd hung up.
哈利法公开谈论他的皈依。他会去传教。他公寓楼里的邻居说他会把伊斯兰宣传单塞进他们的门下，并摘掉他们挂出来的圣诞贺卡。
Khalifa married a Somali woman. They had a kid. And they were getting by on welfare and money Khalifa made selling books. Some of them were books on Islam that he got from a sheik in South Africa. And he'd even started some kind of religious school. In 2006, he started holding classes in his apartment for local Somali children. Again, here's David.
哈利法娶了一位索马里妇女。他们有一个孩子。他们依靠福利和哈利法卖书赚的钱生活。其中一些是他在南非从一个谢赫那里得到的伊斯兰书籍。他甚至开始某种宗教学校。2006年，他开始在公寓里为当地索马里儿童开设课程。再强调一次，这是大卫。
And they called it al-Shabaab, which in Arabic means, "the youth." But it's also the name of the al-Qaeda-affiliated terrorist organization in Somalia. He wasn't aware of that at the time when he named the school.
他们叫它“青年党”(al-Shabaab)，在阿拉伯语中意味着“青年”。但它也是索马里与基地组织有关的恐怖组织的名称。他在命名学校时并不知道这一点。
He was not?
他不知道？
But-- he was not. He did not know that that was the name of a terrorist organization. People mentioned it to him pretty quickly afterwards and said, you know, that's probably not the best name for your school, and it's probably not a great idea to have, like, business cards that say Khalifa al-Akili, Al-Shabaab.
但是——他不知道。他不知道那是一个恐怖组织的名字。人们在那之后很快就对他提到了这件事，并说，你知道，这可能不是你学校的最佳名字，而且印有哈利法·阿基利，“青年党”的名片可能不是个好主意。
But he was kind of defiant and said, well, it means what it means. And if they misinterpret it or they think it means something else, then that's their problem.
但他有点挑衅地说，嗯，它的意思就是它的意思。如果他们误解了或者认为它意味着别的东西，那那是他们的问题。
Yeah, he wasn't trying to hide anything.
是的，他并没有试图隐瞒什么。
No. I mean, he drove around town in a car that said Al-Shabaab Islamic Institute. Like, he picked up students in this vehicle.
没有。我的意思是，他开着一辆写着“青年党伊斯兰学院”的车在城里转。就像，他用这辆车接学生。
Like on the side? What do you mean, it said it on the car?
就像在侧面？什么意思，车身上写着？
Oh, we'll send you a Myspace picture. He literally-- like there's a picture of him posing by the vehicle with a child inside, and it says Al-Shabaab.
哦，我们会发给你一张Myspace照片。他字面上——就像有一张他靠在车边的照片，里面有个孩子，上面写着“青年党”。
Like a big magnetic sign that he'd kind of gotten made and slapped on the side of a minivan.
就像房地产经纪人那种磁性标志，他让人做了然后拍在面包车侧面一样。
The way like a real estate agent does.
就像房地产经纪人做的那样。
Mhm.
嗯。
Yes.
是的。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Over the seven months David and Lyric were following Sharif through his investigation of Khalifa, they'd check in with him every other day or so, filming whenever they could-- in his safe house, on the street, while he was on the phone with his FBI handlers.
在大卫和莉莉克跟踪谢里夫调查哈利法的七个月里，他们大约每隔一天就和他联系一次，只要有机会就拍摄——在他的安全屋，在街上，当他和FBI对接人通话时。
Yeah, what's up, Todd Exactly. I don't have bay'ah to this masjid, and I don't have bay'ah to the imam here, either. And most people, you have bay'ah to the imam. That way you can move around with them. I don't have it.
是的，怎么了，托德。准确地说。我没有对这个清真寺效忠，我也没有对这里的伊玛目效忠。大多数人，你会对伊玛目效忠。这样你可以和他们一起行动。我没有。
It's such an intimate view of an informant's job. And what we see is how much of a counterterrorism investigation-- at least this case-- is really just someone trying very hard to make friends with a total stranger. So Sharif goes to the mosque, hoping to bump into Khalifa. He asks Khalifa out for coffee, offers him rides.
这是一个对线人工作的深刻洞察。我们看到的是，反恐调查——至少在这个案件中——有多少真的只是一个人努力想和一个完全陌生的人交朋友。所以谢里夫去清真寺，希望能撞见哈利法。他约哈利法喝咖啡，主动提出载他一程。
And most of the time, Khalifa just ignores him. Sharif's over-eagerness in all of this is a little hard to watch. He's like the Ned Flanders of FBI stings.
大多数时候，哈利法只是忽略他。谢里夫对这一切的过度渴望有点难以直视。他就像FBI钓鱼执法中的内德·弗兰德斯。
He's constantly texting Khalifa. For example, months into the investigation, Sharif sent Khalifa this text. "As-salaam alaikum, Brother K. What's up? Can you assist me in setting up laptops/Facebook? Inshallah." Here's Lyric.
他不停地给哈利法发短信。例如，调查进行到几个月时，谢里夫给哈利法发了这条短信。“愿安拉赐你平安，K兄弟。怎么了？你能帮我设置一下笔记本电脑/Facebook吗？因沙安拉。”这是莉莉克。
You know, he's not supposed to know how to use Facebook at his age, and I think it was a-- the FBI made that suggestion for Sharif to ask Khalifa to help him set up his Facebook page as a way for Sharif to endear himself to Khalifa, in the sense of like, oh, I'm not knowledgeable in this area. Brother, can you please help me?
你知道，他这个年纪本不应该知道怎么用Facebook，我认为这是一个——FBI给谢里夫提了建议，让他请哈利法帮忙设置Facebook主页，作为谢里夫赢得哈利法好感的一种方式，意思是，哦，我不懂这方面。兄弟，你能帮帮我吗？
Khalifa did not help his Muslim brother. In fact, after Sharif tried to friend Khalifa several times over months, Khalifa blocked him. Sharif then sent Khalifa a text that said, "Why didn't you answer my request? Since you blocked me, you have to request it from me." Khalifa texted back, "It's not that serious, bro. LOL."
哈利法没有帮助他的穆斯林兄弟。事实上，在谢里夫几个月内多次尝试加哈利法好友后，哈利法屏蔽了他。谢里夫给哈利法发了一条短信，“你为什么不回答我的请求？既然你屏蔽了我，你得重新发请求给我。”哈利法回信，“没那么严重，哥们。哈哈。”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
It's hard to see how the FBI thought this was ever supposed to work. Sharif was a lot older than Khalifa. His days as a revolutionary with the Black Panthers were decades ago, and not exactly relevant to a much younger white convert.
很难看出FBI怎么会认为这能成功。谢里夫比哈利法大很多。他作为黑豹党革命者的日子已经是几十年前的事了，与一个年轻得多的白人皈依者并不相关。
Sharif smoked pot, dressed in street clothes. Khalifa proselytized and wore traditional Islamic garb. Lyric and David say Sharif was angry that the FBI hadn't done enough to make him seem believable.
谢里夫抽大麻，穿街头服装。哈利法传教并穿传统的伊斯兰服饰。莉莉克和大卫说谢里夫很生气，因为FBI没能做更多让他看起来可信的事情。
He was really frustrated that the FBI didn't have a cover for him. You know, he said, if I had been a businessman, I could have used that as an entryway and say, oh, Khalifa, you want to set up a shop. And Khalifa did want to set up a shop, I think, a breakfast cafe for people to go to after morning prayer.
他真的很沮丧，FBI没有为他提供伪装。你知道，他说，如果我是一个商人，我就可以把它作为切入点，说，哦，哈利法，你想开一家店。哈利法确实想开一家店，我想，一个早晨祈祷后人们可以去吃的早餐咖啡馆。
And Sharif would say, like, if I had a businessman cover, you know, I could use that as a way to kind of like to keep the conversation going and eventually get to a point where we're talking about money, and you know, what are you going to do for money? If I do this for you, what would you do for me?
谢里夫会说，如果我有商人伪装，你知道，我就可以用它作为一种让对话继续下去的方式，并最终达到一个点，我们谈论钱，你知道，你打算怎么赚钱？如果我为你做这个，你会为我做什么？
There just wasn't like a specific foothold. There wasn't like anything specifically related to Sharif's cover that would initiate an organic conversation about these issues. From what I can tell, it seems to come out of left field every single time.
根本没有像具体的立足点。没有与谢里夫伪装相关的任何具体内容可以开启关于这些问题的有机对话。据我所知，它似乎每次都完全没来由。
For example, one day, as Sharif explains in the film, he was talking with Khalifa, and the classic holy war conversation-starter, camping, came up.
例如，有一天，正如谢里夫在电影中解释的那样，他正在和哈利法交谈，经典的圣战对话开启者，露营，出现了。
That was my key opening right there.  The door opened up for me to make a suggestion now. I said, oh, that's cool, man. We could all go camping. I said, you know, why don't we just go a little further? We could train, man, like we do in the military.
那是我的关键开场。门为我打开了，可以提建议了。我说，哦，太酷了，伙计。我们可以一起去露营。我说，你知道，为什么我们不走远一点？我们可以像在军队里那样训练。
I said, brother-- 'cause he wanted to go and fight for the Muslim State. He said, I gotta consult my sheikh. I said, see, that's what's wrong with you, brother. You brothers always talk that jihad stuff, but when somebody gives you the opportunity to make a move to fight for the Islam, y'all are not gonna fight for the Islam. Y'all talk that talk, but you won't walk the walk.
我说，兄弟——因为他想去为穆斯林国家而战。他说，我得咨询我的谢赫。我说，看，这就是你的问题，兄弟。你们兄弟总是谈论那些圣战的事，但当有人给你机会采取行动为伊斯兰而战时，你们却不会为伊斯兰而战。你们光说不练。
Sharif was supposed to gather evidence, record his conversations for FBI analysis. But when he did manage to speak to Khalifa, he couldn't get Khalifa to say anything that Khalifa hadn't already revealed himself on his Facebook page. So he tried other methods that are familiar, if you've ever followed these kinds of cases.
谢里夫本应收集证据，为FBI分析录下他的谈话。但当他确实设法和哈利法交谈时，他无法让哈利法说出任何哈利法没在Facebook主页上透露过的事情。所以他尝试了其他方法，如果你曾经关注过这类案件，你会很熟悉。
He asked Khalifa to buy him a gun. Sharif said that he needed protection from neighborhood kids who were selling drugs in front of his house. Khalifa didn't bite on that, either.
他让哈利法给他买枪。谢里夫说他需要保护自己，免受在他家门前卖毒品的社区孩子的骚扰。哈利法也没吃这一套。
But the FBI wanted Sharif to keep going. He would text the FBI to tell them what he was up to. "Heading to Friday prayer at al-Noor Mosque. No word from POI."
但FBI希望谢里夫继续努力。他会发短信给FBI告诉他们他在做什么。“正前往诺尔清真寺参加周五祈祷。POI没有消息。”
The FBI would text back, "POI just walked in. Turn recorder on before you go in. Talk to him a little. Get a feel."
FBI会回信，“POI刚刚走进去。进去前打开录音机。和他聊聊。感觉一下。”
Terrorists who commit these acts and those who harbor them.
实施这些行为的恐怖分子以及那些包庇他们的人。
One Sunday night, three months into the investigation, something happened that shows just how hard it is to appear authentic in a situation that's completely fake.
一个周日晚上，调查进行了三个月，发生了一件事，表明在一个完全虚假的情况下表现得真实是多么困难。
She wants out. She asked for--
她想退出。她问——
Lyric and David were filming Sharif in his apartment, watching TV, and Sharif sent this text. "ASA." That's short for As-salaam alaikum. "ASA, Brother K. Check this movie on channel 370, Showtime." And then in parentheses, Sharif adds, " Homeland ."
莉莉克和大卫在谢里夫的公寓里拍他，看电视，谢里夫发了这条短信。“ASA。”那是“愿安拉赐你平安”的缩写。“愿安拉赐你平安，K兄弟。看看370频道Showtime上的这部电影。”然后在括号里，谢里夫补充说，“《国土安全》。”
Khalifa texts back, "Hm, on Netflix?" Sharif responds, "No, Showtime. It's called Homeland . Taliban Warrior." A 63-year-old former Black Panther with decades of experience as a government informant, and the thing he does is text his target about Homeland .
哈利法回信，“嗯，Netflix上有吗？”谢里夫回复，“没有，Showtime。它叫《国土安全》。塔利班战士。”一个63岁的前黑豹党成员，有几十年的政府线人经验，他做的事情竟然是发短信给他的目标谈论《国土安全》。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
By late January 2012, four months into Sharif's involvement in the investigation, Khalifa still hadn't said or done anything that the FBI could use to charge him. No support for terrorism, no plans to engage in any illegal activity.
到2012年1月下旬，谢里夫参与调查四个月后，哈利法仍然没有说或做任何FBI可以用来指控他的事情。没有对恐怖主义的支持，没有参与任何非法活动的计划。
And then one day, Lyric and David saw something on Khalifa's Facebook page that made it clear that this whole game was make-believe. This idea that Sharif was some kind of terrorist recruiter was crumbling.
然后有一天，莉莉克和大卫在哈利法的Facebook主页上看到了让这一切明显是虚构的东西。谢里夫是某种恐怖主义招募者的想法正在崩溃。
Um, I believe his first sort of public inkling that something was wrong, he wrote, "The Feds must think I'm Willie Lump Lump. They think they can send anyone to me." And we knew that that was an indirect reference to Sharif on the ground in Pittsburgh.
嗯，我相信他第一个公开的暗示是出了问题，他写道，“联邦调查局一定以为我是‘威利·伦普·伦普’。他们以为可以随便派个人来找我。”我们知道那是对匹兹堡当地谢里夫的间接指涉。
And then on March 9, 2012, Khalifa posted the following, which he also sent out via email to a bunch of reporters. Quote, "Sometime in September or October of 2011, I met Saeed S. Torres, who introduced himself to me as Sharif."
然后在2012年3月9日，哈利法发布了以下内容，他还通过电子邮件发送给了一群记者。引用，“2011年9月或10月的某个时候，我遇到了赛义德·S·托雷斯，他向我介绍自己为谢里夫。”
And from there, he goes on to make a detailed discovery that Saeed Sharif Torres is in fact an FBI informant. And the last line of his sort of lengthy discovery is, "And I encourage journalists to come and speak to me about these issues, because I would like to sue the FBI for their harassment of me."
从那里，他继续做出详细的披露，赛义德·谢里夫·托雷斯实际上是FBI线人。他冗长披露的最后一行是，“我鼓励记者们过来和我谈谈这些问题，因为我想起诉FBI对我的骚扰。”
All right, you ready?
好的，准备好了吗？
Yeah. My name is Khalifa al-Akili from Pittsburgh. In 1991, I accepted Islam, took shahada.
好的。我叫哈利法·阿基利，来自匹兹堡。1991年，我接受了伊斯兰教，念了清真言。
So David and Lyric took him up on his offer. They went to his apartment, set up their cameras, and never mentioned that they'd been filming Sharif for months, even as Khalifa went on and on about him.
所以大卫和莉莉克接受了他的邀请。他们去了他的公寓，架起摄像机，从未提及他们已经跟踪谢里夫拍了几个月，即使哈利法喋喋不休地谈论他。
He was always talking about the cause, the cause, the cause, you know? And some guys pray, other guys fight.
他总是谈论事业，事业，事业，你知道吗？有些人祈祷，有些人战斗。
Khalifa tells them about the first time he met Sharif. He shows them texts on his phone.
哈利法告诉他们他第一次见到谢里夫的情景。他给他们看手机上的短信。
Trying to see if there's anything of relevance. Oh. Wow, [ARABIC]. On December 18-- now, dig this. Now look.  On December 18, "ASA," which means As-salaam alaikum. "Brother K, check this movie on channel 370, Showtime. It's a series called Homeland ." About terrorists, right? Which I actually did, and I actually enjoyed it.
看看有没有什么相关的。哦。哇，[阿拉伯语]。12月18日——现在，琢磨琢磨。现在看。12月18日，“ASA”，意思是愿安拉赐你平安。“K兄弟，看看370频道Showtime上的这部电影。这是一部叫《国土安全》的连续剧。”关于恐怖分子的，对吧？我真的看了，我也确实很享受。
I do, too. [LAUGHS]
我也喜欢。[笑声]
So but, yeah, he-- it was like, it was to help him talk about that topic. Then-- then like the next-- like he kept talking about this, even on-- this was on the 18th. On the 20th-- now who talks about a show that much? On the 20th, he says, "As-salaam alaikum, Brother K, how you doing? How did you like the show Homeland ? I'll talk tomorrow." [ARABIC].
所以，但是，是的，他——这就好像，这是为了帮他谈论那个话题。然后——然后就像第二天——他甚至在——这是18号的事。20号——现在谁会那么频繁地谈论一个节目？20号，他说，“愿安拉赐你平安，K兄弟，你好吗？你觉得《国土安全》怎么样？明天聊。”[阿拉伯语]。
So he, like, kept wanting to talk to me, even like when we got together or whatever. He wanted to-- so how did you like it? What do you think about it? What do you think about, you know, blowing this up? And just talking crazy.
所以他，就像，一直想跟我说话，甚至当我们聚在一起时。他想——所以你觉得怎么样？你觉得那个怎么样？你觉得，你知道，炸掉这个怎么样？简直是疯了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Let's take a moment here and just count up all the lies that are being told. Lyric and David are lying to Khalifa, pretending they've never met Sharif. But now they're also lying to Sharif, because they don't tell him that they're interviewing Khalifa.
让我们在这里花点时间数一数所有这些谎言。莉莉克和大卫在对哈利法撒谎，假装他们从未见过谢里夫。但现在他们也在对谢里夫撒谎，因为他们没告诉他他们正在采访哈利法。
And of course, this whole story began with a lie. Sharif heard from Lyric that he was working for the FBI. And he hid from the FBI that he'd let Lyric and David film the investigation. And Sharif lied to Khalifa about who he really was. It's turned into this giant knot of lies.
当然，整个故事始于一个谎言。谢里夫从莉莉克那里听说他在为FBI工作。他向FBI隐瞒了他让莉莉克和大卫拍摄调查过程的事。谢里夫还对哈利法撒谎说他到底是谁。事情变成了一个巨大的谎言结。
Once Lyric and David had done their interviews with Khalifa, and gotten away without him figuring out who they really were, they had to keep the lies up. Because lawyers had told them when they started making this film that they had to be careful to never do anything that got in the way of the investigation. If they did, they could be charged with tampering with an active investigation.
一旦莉莉克和大卫完成了对哈利法的采访，并且没让他发现他们到底是谁，他们就必须维持谎言。因为律师在他们开始拍这部电影时告诉过他们，必须小心永远不要做任何阻碍调查的事情。如果他们做了，他们可能会被指控篡改正在进行的调查。
And tampering would include actions such as telling Sharif that we were in contact with Khalifa, and telling Khalifa that we had been filming with Sharif. The FBI could say, but for the presence of these filmmakers, our case would have been successful. But for the presence of these filmmakers, we would've secured this counterterrorism arrest.
篡改包括诸如告诉谢里夫我们与哈利法有联系，以及告诉哈利法我们一直在与谢里夫拍摄之类的行动。FBI可能会说，如果不是这些电影制片人的存在，我们的案件就会成功。如果不是这些电影制片人的存在，我们就会确保这次反恐逮捕。
In the end, what messed up the investigation wasn't the filmmakers or Sharif. It was a mistake the FBI made, a mistake that proved to Khalifa without a doubt that the FBI was spying on him. While Sharif was floundering with Khalifa, the FBI sent in this other informant, Muhammad, to be the closer. Here's a section of the film that explains all this. It alternates between Sharif and Khalifa telling what happened with Muhammad. Here's Sharif.
最后，搞砸调查的不是制片人或谢里夫。这是FBI犯的一个错误，一个向哈利法证明FBI在监视他的无可辩驳的错误。当谢里夫在哈利法那里挣扎时，FBI派出了另一个线人，穆罕默德，去收尾。这是电影中解释所有这些的部分。它交替显示谢里夫和哈利法讲述穆罕默德身上发生的事情。这是谢里夫。
All I was supposed to do was introduce him to Khalifa. Just let him know, yo, I have an individual Muslim's coming in. He's a recruiter for the Taliban, or he's a recruiter for the al-Qaeda. You know, he's a good brother. You know, maybe y'all should meet. Short and simple.
我本该做的只是把他介绍给哈利法。只是让他知道，哟，我有一个正在进入的穆斯林个人。他是塔利班的招募者，或者是基地组织的招募者。你知道，他是个好兄弟。你知道，也许你们应该见个面。简单直接。
Before I could even introduce the fucking dude to the fucking POI, the motherfucker was jumping out my car already, just to meet him. I'm like, what the fuck?
在我还没来得及把那个该死的家伙介绍给该死的POI之前，那个混蛋就已经跳出我的车去见他了。我当时想，什么鬼？
The guy got out, and he came up to me, gave me the greeting of as-salaam alaikum, kissed me on both cheeks. And I swear to you, when I walked away from that situation, I walked away feeling like I'd just played a part in some Hollywood terrorist movie, that I just met, like, the leader of some terrorist organization.
那家伙下车了，他走到我面前，对我说了“愿安拉赐你平安”的问候，亲吻了我的双颊。我向你发誓，当我离开那个现场时，我感觉自己就像在好莱坞恐怖片里演了个角色，我就像见到了某个恐怖组织的领导人。
Actually, right there on the spot, he wanted to go have some coffee or sit down with me. And I told him no, I still have to go visit my mother, and I'm actually on my way there. I'm getting ready to catch a bus to go there. You know, I walked away. He got back in the truck.
实际上，就在当场，他想和我去喝杯咖啡或者坐下来。我拒绝了，我说我还得去探望我母亲，我实际上在去那里的路上。我正准备赶车去那里。你知道，我走开了。他回到了卡车上。
It was so clear that I didn't want to meet these guys. Like, seriously. I literally made up excuse after excuse after excuse.
很明显我不想见这些人。就像，真的。我真的是找了一个接一个的借口。
The next morning, this guy, Muhammad, he was back in Khalifa's neighborhood. And he wanted to know if Khalifa would go to McDonald's with him, have a cup of coffee. Khalifa took the filmmakers to that McDonald's.
第二天早上，这家伙，穆罕默德，又回到了哈利法的社区。他想知道哈利法是否会和他一起去麦当劳喝杯咖啡。哈利法带制片人去了那家麦当劳。
The morning that we all came in here, we actually sat at this first booth right here, and that's whenever he began to talk about his people being involved in jihad and whatnot, and fighting. And this was the location that we sat down and had the coffee with him. So we exchanged numbers, and actually, that morning he drove me home. After that, I didn't hear anything from him.
我们所有人都进来的那天早上，我们实际上坐在这第一个展位，就是当他开始谈论他的人参与圣战之类的，还有战斗。这是我们和他一起喝咖啡的地方。所以我们交换了号码，实际上，那天早上他开车送我回家。在那之后，我就没再听到他的消息了。
But now Khalifa had Muhammad's phone number. Again, David and Lyric.
但现在哈利法有了穆罕默德的电话号码。再说一遍，大卫和莉莉克。
It was written on a receipt, and he kind of tossed it in a drawer or in a closet, and didn't kind of think about it until a few weeks later, when he, I guess, was cleaning his house, and saw the receipt and the number, and was like, oh, yeah, let me follow up on this.
它写在一张收据上，他把它扔在抽屉或壁橱里，没怎么多想，直到几周后，我想，当他在打扫房子看到收据和号码时，就想，哦，对了，让我跟进一下。
It began with area code 518, which is associated with Albany, New York. And he googled the number, and what came back to him, I believe the first result was a court transcript. When he clicked on that court transcript, it said FBI informant, right next to the number. And that number was listed in the US Southern District court transcript from a terrorism trial that happened in 2010, and Khalifa googled this number in 2012. And so he's looking at a two-year-old transcript that is part of the public record that lists this telephone number from Muhammad as belonging to FBI informant Shahed Hussain.
它以518区号开头，与纽约州奥尔巴尼有关。他谷歌了这个号码，回给他的结果，我相信第一个结果是法庭记录。当他点击那个法庭记录时，号码旁边写着FBI线人。那个号码被列在2010年发生的恐怖主义审判的美国南区法庭记录中，而哈利法在2012年谷歌了这个号码。所以他正在看一份两年前的公开记录的一部分，上面列着属于FBI线人沙希德·侯赛因的电话号码。
Once Khalifa figured out that Muhammad was an informant, he started looking for proof that Sharif was, too. And he found it, as he explains in the film.
一旦哈利法弄清楚穆罕默德是线人，他就开始寻找谢里夫也是线人的证据。正如他在电影中解释的那样，他找到了。
Yeah, very, very easy. He left me alone in his truck one time. He went into the store. And I'm getting ready to show you the picture. And when he did that, there was a letter sitting on the dashboard from the welfare office. So I picked it up and I snapped a picture of it. Because I know he was FBI. And that's-- that's him right there, with his real name and his address. Because I was-- you know, I was trying to cross my T's and dot my I's, wanting to know who this guy was. And his real name is a Saeed S. Torres.
是的，非常非常容易。他有一次把我独自留在卡车里。他去了商店。我准备给你看照片。当他那样做时，仪表盘上有一封来自福利办公室的信。所以我把它捡起来，拍了一张照片。因为我知道他是FBI。而这就是——那就是他，真实姓名和地址。因为我当时——你知道，我试着把所有的事都查清楚，想知道这家伙到底是谁。他的真名是赛义德·S·托雷斯。
After Lyric and David filmed Khalifa telling this story, they had to go back to Sharif-- or was he back to being Saeed now? Whatever the case, they couldn't tell him what they knew.
在莉莉克和大卫拍摄了哈利法讲述这个故事后，他们不得不回去找谢里夫——或者他是变回赛义德了？不管怎样，他们不能告诉他他们所知道的。
You know, we could not say anything about Khalifa to Saeed. When sort of Saeed would make these theories about him and say things about his personality, often, you know, we couldn't respond, even though we knew. And Sharif often asked us-- which is information that we knew-- how Khalifa found out his identity. Because Sharif was not checking Khalifa's Facebook, he was not privy to this whole discovery. The FBI did not tell them.
你知道，我们不能对赛义德说关于哈利法的任何事。当赛义德对他的性格提出这些理论并说一些话时，通常，你知道，我们无法回应，即使我们知道。谢里夫经常问我们——这是我们知道的信息——哈利法是如何发现他的身份的。因为谢里夫没有检查哈利法的Facebook，他没有参与整个发现过程。FBI没有告诉他们。
The FBI did not tell him that--
FBI没有告诉他——
No.
没有。
That Khalifa had posted this?
哈利法发布了这个？
No. They did not.
没有。他们没有。
Not at first.
一开始没有。
They just told-- the FBI, in response to Khalifa's discovery, the FBI told Sharif, you need to get out of town now. They did not tell him why.
他们只是告诉——FBI在哈利法发现问题后，告诉谢里夫，你现在得离开城里。他们没告诉他原因。
You all exposed me. You all put me on the goddamn line and left me out there hanging to dry.
你们所有人出卖了我。你们所有人把我扔在该死的线上，就把我挂在那里晾着。
This is Sharif, who's now clearly been outed as an informant, talking on the phone with one of his FBI handlers. He's just found out that Muhammad blew their cover. He's not happy about it.
这是谢里夫，他现在显然已经被揭穿是线人，正在电话里和他的FBI对接人谈话。他刚发现穆罕默德炸毁了他们的掩护。他很不高兴。
Initially, when I did this contact with y'all, if I didn't feel right about something, I wouldn't go through it. But yet y'all forced my hand to go through it.
最初，我接触你们时，如果我对某事感觉不对，我就不会去做。但你们却强迫我去做。
Sharif complained to the filmmakers. He said he was fed up with the FBI and this entire investigation.
谢里夫向制片人抱怨。他说他受够了FBI和整个调查。
And I told them, I said, I'm not here to entrap nobody. They trying to make me force this dude into saying something to support terrorism. I said, the dude is not a fucking terrorist, man. He's not even a pseudo-terrorist. He's nothing but an oxymoron.
我告诉他们，我说，我不是来引诱任何人的。他们试图强迫我让这家伙说出支持恐怖主义的话。我说，这家伙不是个该死的恐怖分子，伙计。他甚至不是个伪恐怖分子。他除了是个反义词什么都不是。
I said, what you all been doing for the last three years? Y'all ain't seen nothing? If you all ain't seen nothing, what y'all expect me to see?
我说，你们过去三年都在做什么？你们什么都没看到？如果你们什么都没看到，你们指望我看到什么？
Still, the FBI continued to tell Sharif to keep up the ruse.
尽管如此，FBI继续告诉谢里夫维持这种诡计。
First saved message, received March 9 at 4:50 PM.
第一条已保存信息，3月9日下午4:50收到。
Hey, it's Jay.
嘿，是杰。
"Hey, it's Jay." This is one of Sharif's FBI handlers. He wants Sharif to send one last text, and here's what he wants it to say.
“嘿，是杰。”这是谢里夫的FBI对接人之一。他想让谢里夫发最后一条短信，这就是他想让他发的。
I don't know who you've been talking to or exactly what you've been saying about me, what got around. People came to my work today and talked to me, and I can't have that.
我不知道你一直在和谁谈话，或者你一直在说我的什么，什么传出去了。今天有人来我工作的地方谈到我，我不能那样。
He tells him not to mention the Feds or the police.
他告诉他不要提及联邦调查局或警察。
Then something like, you know, inshallah. I'll see you around. And, um, change your number. That's what we want. All right, man? Call me if you got any questions.
然后类似，你知道，因沙安拉。我会再见你的。而且，嗯，换个号码。这就是我们想要的。好了，伙计？有任何问题就打电话给我。
But you see what I'm saying? I'm heading home. And you see what they still asking me?
但你明白我的意思吗？我正在回家。你看到他们还在要求我做什么吗？
In other words, their target had figured out that Muhammad and Sharif were both fake identities, both working for the FBI. But Sharif was still being asked by the FBI to pretend like nothing had gone wrong.
换句话说，他们的目标已经发现穆罕默德和谢里夫都是虚假身份，都在为FBI工作。但FBI仍然要求谢里夫装作什么都没发生过。
Sharif told Lyric that he's no longer an FBI informant, that they don't respond to his calls or texts. They've gone completely silent.
谢里夫告诉莉莉克他不再是FBI线人了，他们不再回复他的电话或短信。他们已经完全沉默了。
And Khalifa? Well, Khalifa had planned to go public with everything-- everything he'd written in that Facebook post, everything he'd told David and Lyric. And he'd been in touch with lawyers at an advocacy group called Project Salaam that provides legal help for Muslims. Khalifa was going to go down to DC and be part of a press conference where he'd lay out the whole story. The day before the press conference, David was supposed to meet him early to film him going to morning prayer.
那哈利法呢？好吧，哈利法已经计划公开一切——他写在Facebook帖子里的每一件事，他告诉大卫和莉莉克的每一件事。他一直与一个叫“沙拉姆计划”的倡导团体的律师保持联系，该团体为穆斯林提供法律援助。哈利法打算去华盛顿参加新闻发布会，在那里他会把整个故事讲出来。新闻发布会前一天，大卫应该早点去和他见面，拍摄他去晨祷的过程。
And I showed up outside of his house. I pull around the corner, I notice all these black SUVs out front. And you know, it's probably about 5:30 in the morning, and I knew exactly what was going on.
我出现在他家门外。我把车开到拐角处，注意到门前全是这些黑色SUV。你知道，大概是凌晨5:30，我知道发生了什么。
I haven't done anything to anybody.
我没对任何人做过任何事。
--And get that squared away.
——把那个处理好。
The Prophet Muhammad, salla ilahu, he said, "Beware of the supplication of the person who is unjustly treated." This is wrong. I haven't done anything to anyone.
先知穆罕默德说，“要当心被不公正对待的人的祈求。”这不对。我没对任何人做过任何事。
Khalifa was in handcuffs, being arrested by the FBI.
哈利法被戴上手铐，被FBI逮捕了。
Khalifa had met with his lawyer a few days earlier, who had said, you know, if they're going to come for you, it's going to be either late at night or early in the morning. And so fortunately, I had the camera set up.  I just grabbed it and jumped out of the car.
哈利法几天前见过他的律师，律师说，你知道，如果他们要来抓你，不是在深夜就是在凌晨。所以幸运的是，我架好了摄像机。我只是抓起它跳下车。
Can you please try to get ahold of someone to help my wife, please? Please, man.
请帮我联系人来帮帮我妻子，好吗？求你了，伙计。
The FBI arrested Khalifa not for terrorism charges, but on a gun charge. Khalifa, remember, was a felon. He'd done time for a narcotics charge. So he wasn't legally supposed to possess a firearm. But one day, years before, he went to a public firing range, borrowed a friend's gun, and shot at a target. His friend took a seven-second video and emailed it to Khalifa.
FBI逮捕哈利法不是因为恐怖主义指控，而是因为枪支指控。记住，哈利法是重罪犯。他因毒品指控服过刑。所以他法律上不允许持有枪支。但有一天，多年前，他去了一个公共射击场，借了朋友的枪，向一个目标射击。他的朋友拍了一段七秒的视频并用电子邮件发给了哈利法。
And basically, that friend was called in to the grand jury, and basically, the friend had to admit, yes, I emailed this photo to Khalifa. Yes, this photo was taken at a shooting range, wherein Khalifa was holding a gun. And that's all the information they needed, in combination with that photo, led to confirmation that Khalifa was indeed a felon in possession of a firearm. And he received a sentence of eight years.
基本上，那个朋友被传唤到大陪审团，基本上，那个朋友不得不承认，是的，我把这张照片发电子邮件给了哈利法。是的，这张照片是在哈利法持枪的射击场拍摄的。这就是他们需要的所有信息，结合那张照片，导致了确认哈利法确实是持有枪支的重罪犯。他被判了八年。
And yet his public defender, who said she's handled thousands of gun cases throughout her career, she said she has never once seen someone being prosecuted based on a photograph of them at a gun range. You know, the vast majority of the time, it's someone who's caught in criminal activity.
然而他的公设辩护律师，她说她在职业生涯中处理过成千上万起枪支案件，她说她从来没见过有人因为一张在射击场的照片而被起诉。你知道，绝大多数情况下，那是被抓到犯罪活动的人。
Khalifa had gone to the gun range in 2010, and he hadn't tried to hide it. For a while, a picture of him holding the gun had been his Facebook profile picture. Which means the FBI could've made this arrest almost two years earlier, long before they dragged Sharif into their investigation.
哈利法在2010年去过射击场，他没试图隐瞒。有一阵子，他持枪的照片甚至是他的Facebook头像。这意味着FBI本可以在近两年前就进行这次逮捕，早在他们把谢里夫拖入调查之前。
The FBI did not comment for Lyric and David's film. And when we approached them, they provided this statement. "The FBI's use of undercover operations and informants across all criminal and national security programs is done in accordance with strict guidelines and in close coordination with the Department of Justice and the United States Attorney's offices."
FBI没有对莉莉克的电影置评。当我们找到他们时，他们发表了这份声明。“FBI在所有刑事和国家安全项目中对卧底行动和线人的使用，都是按照严格指导方针并在与司法部和美国检察官办公室密切协调下进行的。”
The person I really wanted to talk to about this whole experience is Sharif, see what he thinks now that he's seen Lyric and David's film and he knows the truth from all sides. And it seemed like he'd be game to talk.
关于整个经历，我真正想谈谈的人是谢里夫，看看他在看过莉莉克和大卫的电影并了解各方真相后有什么想法。他似乎也乐意谈谈。
But at the last minute, he turned me down. Lyric says it's because I called him an informant in an email. He considers himself to be a civilian operative, Lyric told me. He knows that some people look down on informants, and he was offended that I used the word.
但在最后一刻，他拒绝了我。莉莉克说是因为我在电子邮件里叫他线人。他认为自己是文职特工，莉莉克告诉我。他知道有些人看不起线人，而我用这个词冒犯了他。
Lyric says that when Sharif finally had a chance to watch the movie, he had one critique. "I look fucking depressed all the time," he said.
莉莉克说，当谢里夫终于有机会看这部电影时，他提出了一个批评。“我看起来一直很沮丧，”他说。
For 23 years, Saeed Sharif Torres had been doing informant work, coming up with a new version of himself each time for each new target. He's a shell of what he once was, Lyric told me. Lying to people for a living can take a toll on you. Now he could finally see it.
23年来，赛义德·谢里夫·托雷斯一直在做线人工作，每次为每个新目标编造一个新的自己。他已经成了他过去的一个空壳，莉莉克告诉我。以说谎为生会让你付出代价。现在他终于看到了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Jonathan Menjivar is one of the producers of our program. The documentary (T)ERROR will be released in theaters on October 7. You can find out more at terrordocumentary.org.
乔纳森·门吉瓦尔是我们节目的制作人之一。纪录片《恐怖》(T)ERROR将于10月7日在影院上映。你可以在 terrordocumentary.org 了解更多信息。
[MUSIC - GEORGE JACKSON, "WILLIE LUMP LUMP"]
[音乐 - 乔治·杰克逊，《威利·伦普·伦普》]
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Production help from Lily Sullivan.
我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德制作，佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛维尔。朱莉·斯奈德是我们的编辑顾问。莉莉·沙利文提供了制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator.
塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的业务运营经理。埃尔娜·贝克为我们的节目寻找故事。金伯利·亨德森是我们的办公室协调员。
Research help today from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯维塔拉提供了研究帮助。达米安·格雷夫和罗伯·格迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
George RR Martin's talk that you heard a little bit of at the top of the program took place at the 92nd Street Y in New York City. They have a video of that online.
你在节目开头听到的乔治·R·R·马丁演讲的一小部分是在纽约市的第92街Y中心进行的。他们在网上有那个视频。
Special thanks today to Christopher St. John, to Charlotte Street Films, to Trevor Aaronson, and Brad Torgersen, and Craig Zobel.
今天特别感谢克里斯托弗·圣约翰、夏洛特街电影公司、特雷弗·亚伦森、布拉德·托格森和克雷格·佐贝尔。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who this week took over management of Rhode Island Public Radio in Providence. No kidding. They are lucky to have them. I really, truly wanted to make a big deal out it here at the end of the program and congratulate him, but he would not let me.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他本周接管了普罗维登斯的罗德岛公共广播电台的管理工作。没开玩笑。他们很幸运拥有他。我真的非常想在节目结尾对此大做文章并祝贺他，但他不让我这样做。
"It's not that serious, bro. LOL."
“没那么严重，哥们。哈哈。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - GEORGE JACKSON, "WILLIE LUMP LUMP"]
[音乐 - 乔治·杰克逊，《威利·伦普·伦普》]